the vessel's registered as the
chetsamoka
and is broadcasting a message on a loop
message follows
holden's knuckles hurt and he forced
himself to relax his fist
naomi's voice filled the ops deck and it
was like being on the verge of passing
out from dehydration
and being handed a glass of water as
dire as the message
was holden still felt every syllable
untying his knots
when naomi's message was done he fell
back in his couch
limp as a rag she was in trouble but it
was trouble they could fix
she was on her way back toward him thank
you mr patel holden said
in thanks you may now have all my stuff
i don't care about any of it anymore
including the coffee maker sir almost
all my stuff
hey guys pete here it's time to break
down the expanse season 5 episode 8 hard
vacuum
we're inching closer to the crew of the
rossi coming back together
or maybe marco's plan will work out and
the chatsumoka bomb will take out the
majority of our main
players that seems unlikely but i'll
readily admit that i would be okay with
watching a season six that involved
avasarala
amos and drummer hunting down the free
navy before we get into what happened in
episode 8 this is your spoiler warning
if you're not completely caught up with
the expanse tv series
through season 5's eighth episode then
this video won't be for you as someone
who's read all the books i will be
referring to them but i won't be giving
away any future spoilers
with all that out of the way let's get
started we are
officially setting the table for the end
game and that means we do check in with
all the different stories in this
episode
let's look towards the inner planets
first we catch up with amos and clarissa
who
are biking their way to baltimore things
are looking pretty deserted there aren't
very many people around
they stop to take a leak and don't feel
the need to stay out of view
we find out that peaches is starting to
feel like herself she's starting to feel
better now that the blocker meds are
leaving her system
outside what they think is an old
people's home they come across some dead
bodies which doesn't feel like a great
sign for things to come
and they decide that they need to get
off the planet later when they arrive at
eric's headquarters where we see that
baltimore looks pretty destroyed she
brings up winnipesaukee island
and this is what she was talking to amos
about earlier when she said that she had
an idea of where they could find the
ship
eric is essentially in denial about
what's really happening and he lays it
out in a way that's relatable
he spent his whole life building this up
he came from nothing
he built up this criminal enterprise
being the leader of a gang is a pretty
chaotic existence in normal times so he
does have some skills that would lend
themselves to a near apocalypse
but from what he says it sounds like
most of his territory is gone
clarissa tells him a story from prison
which is straight out of the books and i
always liked how it emphasized how
transformative the asteroid attack
is she tells eric about a woman she was
locked up with that killed her children
the woman talked about them like they
were still alive
and this made clarissa think she was
crazy until one day she comes up to her
and she says i know they're dead but i
know i'm dead too
you're the only [ __ ] in here who thinks
she's still alive
in that moment clarissa realized that
who she was before she went to prison
is basically dead and as she tells eric
we see
this happening to him as well he
realizes that everything he's built up
has been wiped away and he's gonna have
to go
and do something else i've been working
on an amos and peaches video
and when i was re-reading for that i was
really hoping they would include this
exchange
i love how this shows what a great pair
they make as she's meeting eric where
he's at helping to convince
him of what needs to happen so they can
survive amos is over there thinking
about what they need to take with them
in order to pull it off
and since it's difficult to get good
tequila away from earth
i thought it was hilarious that it's
what he's thinking about when his
childhood
friend is having a breakdown in the end
eric is on board and i couldn't help but
notice this
helicopter kind of thing that's in the
background and maybe that'll be
important
on luna we see david pastor stepping
into his role as the
acting secretary general it's like he
fixes his hair and he becomes a new
person
but seriously as he's giving this speech
which is moving
we see him sort of starting to believe
it himself that he is the leader of the
un
avasarala is also impressed and says
that the people saw the leader they
needed to see
and he closes by saying now we just have
to make good on what i said
in their meeting there's a disagreement
over proportional response plans
the secretary general feels like they
have to show the citizens that they can
go on the offensive while avasarala
doesn't want to send the wrong message
she doesn't want to kill innocent
belters which is what delgado's plan
will do
it's an interesting exchange marco is
trying to position himself as the
military arm of the belters but there's
no central government to hold
accountable
people who live in the belt didn't
choose marco to be their leader and most
of them wouldn't have agreed with his
violent methods
later when you see pastor talk to
delgado who for the record really wants
to blow up palestine to send a message
you get the feeling that this might
actually do more harm than good
actions like these could radicalize
belters who are worried about their
survival
we saw this with the drummer faction and
if that happens marco could use that to
his advantage
in unifying the belt it's a difficult
situation
and i guess my takeaway is that
avasarala has the kind of experience
that you would hope would be in that
room speaking of marco we get one scene
on the pela
where he's looking at sin's dead body he
appears to be grieving the loss of his
crewmate and asked philip what he saw he
explains that sin went after her tried
to stop her but that naomi
opened the door and went outside she
wanted to die
and he doesn't understand why she had to
kill sin
marco quickly turns and says that she
didn't kill him
you did and this is interesting because
most of the times when we've seen
marco and philip together he's kind of
played the loving father
here we just see cruelty i guess we'll
have to wait and see why that
is that's all the marco and philip we
get in this episode
and i guess we can gather that her
escape did work they do think
that she killed herself at this point
elsewhere in space on the rasanante
holden and crew don't see signs of the
protomolecule
in the blast zone of the zamaya there's
some discussion about whether the sample
could be destroyed in this way
and holden says that's exactly how
they've done it successfully in the past
based on the flight information they
don't think it could have been passed
off somewhere else
and it seems like this is enough
evidence for jim because
really he's just worried about naomi he
says to set a course for the razorback
and we see a look on monica's face that
says she's not satisfied that the story
of the protomolecule sample is over yet
on top of that bull reveals that he
doesn't like the idea of going on a
suicide mission to save naomi
and as he points out later they did use
a lot of bullets in their last
engagement
on the razorback alex and bobby aren't
having much luck looking for the
chatsumoka
bobby decides to check the radio
thinking that if the free navy had
attacked some ships then they would be
sending out distress calls
when she's doing that she comes across
the distressed call from the chet's
mocha
she passes the message on to the ross
ante and this is where that excerpt that
i opened the video came from
now holden has something that he thinks
he can fix and they don't even have to
confirm what he's going to do because
you can just look at his face and know
that they're going after naomi at this
point
naomi wakes up on the tetsumoka they do
a great job of showing how her time in
vacuum messed her up
she's in pain she's swollen she can
barely stand
the ship is moving so she struggles with
the thrust gravity
all the controls are broken and she
realizes it's rigged with explosives
and as we hear her voice coming into
focus we hear the fake distress call
using her voice
transmitting a message she never
actually recorded we get an
understanding of what marco's plan was
we spend a decent amount of time
watching naomi fight this
impossible situation it's gripping in
her desperation and her struggle through
the pain
and dominique tipper really delivers an
amazing performance
the situation can be summed up like this
the chet smoker has been stripped by
belters and that means
nothing that might be useful would be
left behind she's trying to figure out
what she can do with the little that she
has to work with
and she believes that the explosives are
triggered by a proximity sensor
so she's essentially on a bomb and if
anybody comes too close
then they'll be taken out she does find
some vacuum suits but they don't have
air bottles and she gets one of the
radios to work
transmits a warning message but has no
idea if anybody will actually hear that
we watch as she comes up with a plan
she has access to the space between the
ship's halls where she looks for the
wiring for the calm system
the area inside the outer hall is hard
vacuum and the suit that she wears
doesn't have an
air bottle but it does have seals
basically she
just has the air that's inside it when
she puts on the helmet
which means she can only go out there
and survive for a couple of minutes at a
time
after several brutal trips we see her
find the wire she's looking for
and how she plans on getting a message
out all she can do
is interrupt the transmission so she
changes it
so that instead of saying the full
message all they hear
is this is naomi nagata tell james
holden
i'm in control and she's only able to do
this a few times before she runs out of
air again
before she goes back inside she disables
it so the message stops broadcasting
really it's not much but it is an
ingenious solution
based on what she had at her disposal
it's a small
triumph but at this point she does know
because she can receive messages that
the razorback is on its way
and so she has to hope that this change
in the message
will set off some red flags for them
we do see this message come through on
the dewalt but there's a lot of stuff
that happens within the drummer faction
that we have to talk about before we get
there
when we first catch up with them they're
salvaging a bunch of destroyed ships
we learned that they belong to the matar
kubalea faction
who voted to kill marco back in season
four
drummer corrects things by saying that
they're scavengers not salvagers
marco kills those that defy him and they
pick the bodies clean we
see that there's tension building within
the family later when oxana talks to
drummer alone
she brings up the idea that hey we made
this choice together and it was the
right choice
and drummer understands this but she's
still not sure she can do it
even though oksana rightly points out
that they're still together they're
still
alive and while it's not ideal that is
something
drummer's struggling the family's
struggling and carol is there to kind of
piss everybody off at every turn
there's a moment where she's listening
to a call on the radio
and kind of staring at the captain's
chair and while we're definitely not
supposed to like this character
i do really enjoy the performance the
actor is really good at portraying how
much this person would get under your
skin
she's dedicated to the free navy's cause
and she's there to make sure that
drummer and her faction don't get any
ideas about double crossing marco
in between all the tension there's this
great scene with the water bottle that
sort of sandwiched in between there i
thought it was pretty effective to show
that
even though they're kind of at each
other's throats at this point they're
really not feeling the situation that
they're in
that they are in fact a family and
that's built on something
and it's good to see that they all think
about that when they're together in this
scene
temporarily that does seem to help them
make peace with their decision
and later when coral says that they're
supposed to meet up with two other free
navy ships and go to series
drummer appears to be on board with
following her orders
which include engaging with any
internships they come across
as they're getting ready to do that
though they hear naomi's distress
call drummer immediately wants to go
after her but coral tells her it's a
fake
and that naomi is dead and she tells her
the whole story
in the moment that's too much for
drummer and she loses it
she almost shoots her right there but
she doesn't and then she goes to her
cabin and she gets that bottle that she
had given to ashford and she starts
drinking
drummer's famous temper i made a post
about this on the post episode
discussion on the subreddit and another
user pointed out that in
episode 408 when she's talking to
ashford she tells him that she only
drinks when she's angry
not when she's sad and if we needed more
confirmation
i think we could say without a doubt
that drummer is angry
later karol and oxana talk pearl gives
her some backstory telling her that she
used to be close with naomi
as well and essentially why she thinks
she only cares about herself
as they're talking she gets a
notification and realizes that the
message stopped transmitting they listen
and they see that it has been altered
this makes oxana wonder if someone could
be on the ship could it be naomi
and all karol can say is it can't be
it's impossible
because she does believe that naomi's
dead we hear the message again
as the credits come up and it's a pretty
fantastic ending
so boy we really are getting close to
the end of the season now
what did i think of episode 8 well i
enjoy the character development stuff
since i already know where the story's
going
and i wasn't disappointed in any of that
here it's been keeping up a pretty high
level of tension
and it does feel like it has some good
momentum building going into the end the
political stuff is under the surface
and since this is a story about this
crew who now are split up we want it to
matter when they do come back together
i was actually impressed with how well
they were able to adapt naomi's struggle
on the tetsumoka
a lot of that is carried by the
performance but considering we don't
have any of her thoughts to guide us
through what she's doing
i thought they pulled it off because by
the end we could see how little she had
to work with and just how much of a
badass she is on multiple different
levels
she thinks like an engineer and she
solves problems in that way
here she takes stock of what's available
and comes up with something
knowing it's not much but also knowing
she's not ready to give up yet either
she's on a bomb and she knows her family
is coming to look for
its very own brand and it highlights
what a great character she is
talking about on bran my man holden is
back
he's ready to jump in and get to some
rescuing i don't think it's surprising
in any way that he would do exactly that
but at the same time i think the whole
way that section was set up was just
screaming that the protomolecule sample
hasn't been destroyed
i guess i'll dive a little deeper into
that when i put out my next video in a
couple of days
but i did think monica's look there
stood out she looks like she has
something on her mind and i wonder what
she knows that she's not telling them
the next episode is titled winnipesaukee
so i guess that means that amos clarissa
and eric will make it there
the stuff around the new secretary
general is also pretty interesting
initially it seemed like they were
showing that this guy was going to sort
of
step aside and let abasara make all the
decisions
now it looks like he might be stepping
up into this role
and that might not really go well for
him either i'm curious to see where that
all goes because
it's a pretty messed up situation
they're still really not talking about
how bad the situation on earth is
we hear things like millions of deaths
and counting
we see dead bodies outside an old folks
home where people moved on and didn't
bother to
bury them or anything the exterior shot
of baltimore looked pretty bad
but it seems like a choice at this point
it makes me feel like there's going to
be a reveal but we'll have to wait and
see
the drummer's stuff was all fantastic
what a complicated knot of [ __ ] she
finds herself
in there is a lot going on over here all
the performances were solid
g is always great i mentioned that i
thought coral was doing a really
effective job there
and also oxana has been great as well
i'm not sure what they're setting up
there but they're definitely setting
something up and i can't wait to see
what happens
and i think that's a good place to leave
it let me know in the comments what you
thought about episode 8
where do you think things are going
what's happening with drummer
what's going to happen on luna what's
going to happen on the chat's mocha
let me know what you think please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already
i'll have a follow-up video to this in a
couple of days so make sure you check
back for that
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon